Oh
for many Texans the show goes on
whatever pandemic or not public health
officials have been warning against just
this kind of gathering but in Giddings
Lee County they weren't going to miss
out most has shrugged off the worry of
catching the deadliest virus on the
planet today and don't want to wear
masks because I'm an American and I feel
like I should be able to do what I want
to I'll pay my taxes I live free I want
to be free because it's against their
constitutional rights they shouldn't be
able to hit take what I wear
[Music]
this could all prove pivotal and how the
country contains the infection and
there's worse to come according to the
experts one of the worst parts of the
epidemic the numbers are increasing
dramatically the predictions are as
terrible as these numbers are this is
the beginning they will double in the
next two weeks and then double again the
week after that it's a very different
scene in the center of Houston where the
hospitals are teetering close to
capacity the streets are mostly deserted
even those restaurants open are largely
empty and there's anger at the president
of being a leader and doing what's right
for what's safe for his people the
sudden breaks on the economy has caused
a shocking need the queue for these food
handouts went on for five hours
many resorting to this for the first
time oh my life do I've been the one to
go and get it on my own and now I have
to depend upon you know someone else to
help feeding it out so we're just doing
whatever we have to do you know just to
get by the other day the frustration
amongst the volunteers is palpable
[Applause]
it's like the government woke up one day
decided it co people go and then we
weren't going to talk about it anymore
and yet you can see out here people are
hurting people need people have these
people have people are sick people are
dying
testing sites are overwhelmed
this one is run by a charity and health
workers have seen the numbers going into
hospital triple within weeks and they're
still rising
yes it's way out of control in our
response is also not in an organized
fashion enough to get it in control
we've got to we can't get the toothpaste
back in the tube now but we got to stop
squeezing the tube and do what we can
with those that are not being able to
get things done but some resent any
action to curtail the disease even
taking issue with those like us for
wearing masks content when you pass out
don't ask me for help because I'm not
going to help you because you're wearing
a mascot of stupidity and you're further
pushing the agenda and the agenda is the
deep state which wants to control all of
us and have us living in fear and
thinking that you're contaminated it is
false narrative and when you wear a mask
which you can certainly do you were
further pushing the agenda that is
condemning all of us and keeps us living
in a state of terror she's not alone in
those views and with record numbers of
infections and hospitalizations in
several circumstance
celebrations like this one may lead to
yet another surge Alex Crawford Sky News
Texas